la culture techno appartient à la
culture d'aujourd'hui longtemps elle
avait été mal compris je rejeté écarté
enfin elle est pleinement reconnue et on
sent ici un sentiment de joie et pas
seulement parmi les praticiens de la
technologie par le parmi le grand public
la drogue dans les rêves parties est une
préoccupation majeure vous en convenait
Jack Lang non mais c'est une
préoccupation majeure partout dans la
société je crois que il ne faut pas
mélanger ou associés techno et drogue
est un problème d'ensemble qu'il faut
poser sur le plan national au-delà de la
reconnaissance de la culture techno
c'est tout un message de vie qui est
transmis ici un message d'ouverture un
message de respect un message d'amitié
et ça a été ressenti pas seulement par
les jeunes mais par toutes les
générations merci Jack Lang d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions place
de la Nation et j'imagine que vous allez
continuer la fête et la nuit sera sans
doute longue
merci à vous et ben venez nous venez
nous rejoindre par la nation